right now it seems like almost everyone
is talking about zack snyder's justice
league the director's cut of the 2017
film is making waves for its
many changes to the original including a
four hour run time
a restored 4x3 aspect ratio and newly
added dc characters like darkseid
martian manhunter and the joker to name
a few and the movie is doing well with
critics and audiences alike earning a 73
critic score on rotten tomatoes and
currently holding a 96
rating from audiences superman actor
henry campbell has taken to instagram to
praise snyder's work
writing here's to you zack
congratulations i know this has been an
arduous journey for you you kept
fighting though i couldn't be happier to
see your vision for justice league
realized
and what a movie it is but perhaps the
one part of the film that has grabbed
the most attention
is the scene involving the joker and
batman at the end of the film
batman is joined by cyborg mira flash
deathstroke and the joker the team is
fighting a dark side controlled
evil superman in a post-apocalyptic
wasteland known as
nightmare we've previously seen this
world in snyder's 2016 film batman vs
superman dawn of justice
in a scene in which a gun-toting batman
fights an evil superman
batman is captured unmasked and right as
he's about to be killed by superman
bruce wayne wakes up realizing it was
all just a vision
in zack snyder's justice league viewers
returned to the nightmare timeline in
which aquaman
lois lane wonder woman and harley quinn
have all been killed
it's an incredibly tense and exciting
scene in which meera swears revenge for
aquaman's death
cyborg and flash look moody and most
notably of all
the joker taunts batman over the friends
and family he's lost
and it's toward the end of the scene
when batman promises to kill
joker slowly that something happens for
the first time in
hollywood history batman drops an f-bomb
now this moment is significant for many
reasons
it helps demonstrate to the audience how
batman is truly beyond any moral
reckoning at this point
essentially showing a side to the
character that the movies have never
really tackled up to this point
it also conveys just how dire the
nightmare scenario could be considering
batman is still willing to work with the
joker to set things right
the whole scene is also something of a
breath of fresh air for dc
fans a proper batman joker scene hasn't
really happened for a while
at least not since heath ledger and
christian bale took each other on in
christopher nolan's the dark knight
i think you and i are destined to do
this forever
and for years snyder had wanted to
reunite the characters for a scene
together
as snyder's wife and producing partner
deborah told inverse
zach really wanted to do a scene with
batman and the joker this was our last
hurrah he was like this is my last
chance
i'm going to get to do this scene and
trying to work backward and think like
okay how do i fit that in meanwhile
snyder told ign that he thought a scene
between the two was a necessary part of
his movie
saying i think without a scene where
they get to air their dirty laundry
about each other
i felt like we were getting shortchanged
as fans of the dc universe
that was the hope that we would get to
see them come together but also in
particular
reflecting on each other and their
struggle with each other so that was
really fun for me
funnily enough this dream sequence
happened to be the only scene in the
film that was made specially for the
snyder cut
the whole scene took just three days to
shoot not counting the many years it
took for snyder to convince jared leto
to return as the joker
of course luckily it seems like snyder's
effort has paid off
and dc fans finally have another great
joker scene to add to the history books
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite movies are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
you